hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar influenza 2018 to 2019
are you ready
I'm Judy O'Rourke of laberd's and I'll
be moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab routes the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
Dyess foreign molecular continually
monitors a major flu databases and tests
emerging flu strains on an ongoing basis
ninety-two strains have been validated
with more strains tested regularly to
provide confidence in your results this
presentation is brought to you by daya
sore and molecular Dyson molecular
manufactures and distributes innovative
molecular diagnostic products for
hospital and reference labs the
company's products help laboratories
consolidate testing streamlined
processes and increase efficiency its
simplex and molecular diagnostic kits
are designed for use on the company's
versatile liaison mdx platform the
simplex of flu a B and RSV direct kit
provides simple direct detection and
differentiation of influenza A virus
influenza B virus and RSV with greater
than 97 percent sensitivity to learn
more visit molecular Soren comm let's
get started you can pose questions to
the speaker during the presentation
while they're fresh in your mind to do
so simply type them into the drop-down
box located on the far left of your
screen labeled ask a question and click
on the send button questions will be
answered after the presentation to
enlarge slide window click on the arrows
at the top right hand corner of the
presentation window if you experience
any technical problem seeing or hearing
the presentation just click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by typing it into the answer
question box located on the far left of
your screen
this is an educational webinar and the
suffers free continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located at the top
right of the presentation window and
follow the process of obtaining your
credits I now present today's speaker JM
Lieberman MD medical director for
pediatrics and PR a health sciences dr.
Lieberman is a specialist in pediatric
infectious diseases having completed his
residency training in pediatrics at
Children's Hospital of Los Angeles and
fellowship training in pediatric
infectious diseases at Children's
Hospital of Los Angeles and at Harbor
UCLA Medical Center dr. Lieberman joined
PRA Health Sciences as a medical
director in 2017 after four years as a
regional medical director for Merck
vaccines prior to that he was medical
director of infectious diseases at quest
Diagnostics and laboratory director for
focused diagnostics and infectious
diseases reference lab owned by quest
before joining quest in 2007 dr.
Lieberman was professor of clinical
pediatrics at the University of
California Irvine and chief of
infectious diseases at Miller Children's
Hospital in Long Beach his clinical
research activities have included the
evaluation of vaccines
other biologics and anti microbials and
children he has published articles on a
wide variety of infectious disease
topics and was frequently an invited
lecturer at national and international
meetings his complete bio is found on
the lab routes website
dr. Lieberman will now begin his
presentation
Judy thank you very much greetings
everybody it is my pleasure to be
talking to you today about influenza
making sure that you're ready both from
a professional and a personal standpoint
for the upcoming influenza season
this is a picture of my family a number
of you many of you I presume if heard me
speak in the past I like to keep you
updated with what's going on in my
family I hope you realize this is a
picture from Halloween this is not our
our normal attire my family we don't
believe in these you know group family
pictures where we all dress the same the
kind of rock our individuality my wife
and my son are ninjas two of my
daughters are from Alice in Wonderland
I've got a daughter who's a dinosaur and
I'm a Starfleet captain one of the
things that I like to do for Halloween
is I usually dress up as a king or a
captain some kind of person in charge
because it means for at least one day
out of the year I can pretend to be in
charge of this of this crew we had a lot
of fun on Halloween what Halloween means
of course is it's its fault it means
that the holidays are coming up and it
also means that influenza season is
right around the corner so so let's talk
about influenza and I want to start with
a couple of clinical cases because there
are a number of misperceptions about
influenza that affect how how people
think about it what they do to try to
prevent it and how they treat it and
unfortunately one perception is that the
flu may not be so bad
and indeed in many people it's a
frustrating annoying illness but it also
caused a lot of morbidity and mortality
as we'll talk about in just a little bit
and so on resent to cases from my time
working at a Children's Hospital the
first case this was a previously healthy
eight month old male admitted to a
24-hour history of irritability didn't
actually have any fever of a history of
fever cough or rhinorrhea on assistive
examination he was irritable and
diffusely hypertonic his eyes were open
but he would not fix and follow the
patient's mother said that
she has the flu about five days earlier
a lumbar puncture was performed no
obvious plio psychosis but a markedly
elevated CSF protein a CT scan of the
brain showed a one point five centimeter
hypo dense area in the deep white matter
he was mentally responsive for the first
week but he didn't prove gradually but
even at discharge he was not normal he
was not able to feed he was discharged
home with the g-tube we did an extensive
evaluation for possible etiologies of
his encephalitis and the only positive
result we got was a CSF group influenza
B this was before widespread PCR use not
that we were done PCR for influenza from
the CSF this is a very unusual case but
this patient had influenza encephalitis
and I don't have long-term follow-up but
even a couple months later he's still
not returned to his neurologic baseline
next case a little more typical
bad outcome for influenza this is a
previously healthy 21 month old male
admitted initially to an outside
hospital with four days of fever
decreased activity progressive coughs
and respiratory distress
he's been prescribed amoxicillin for the
acute otitis media the day before he was
admitted and the chest x-ray showed an
extensive right-sided pneumonia upon
admission as laboratories were
significant for a low white count with
20% CEG's and 26% Bam's
he was started on the intravenous
cefuroxime but he rapidly deteriorated
when he arrived in our pediatric
intensive care unit he was in shock and
respiratory failure his tracheal
aspirant was positive for influenza his
blood grew mr essay and he had mr saye
pneumonia and mrs a sepsis
this is a picture of him that I took
upon admission he was critically ill
requiring ventilator support support for
his blood pressure and the most striking
things on physical examination you can
see where his extremities he survived
this infection but he required a left
below the knee amputation and required
half of his right foot to be amputated
as well and so this is a consequence of
his mrs a texas why do you have mrs a
sepsis because he had influenza and one
of the complications of influenza is
secondary bacterial infections and had
he not gotten influenza he would not
have gotten mrs a texas when i gently
kind of probed with the parent about
whether or not even back stood against
influenza she commented that they'd
actually been to their doctor several
weeks earlier the pediatrician and she'd
asked about a flu shot but the
pediatrician said no he didn't need one
because he was healthy this is the
consequence
so again influenza can be a very serious
disease with significant complications
even in otherwise healthy individuals so
the virus is an RNA virus of the ortho
mix of virus family and i emphasize here
that we're talking about influenza and
one of the other problems with influenza
this often gets abbreviated as flu and
the flu is a nonspecific term that
people use for a variety of illnesses
that may or may not be caused by
influenza as much as possible I'm gonna
say influen to remind you that it's a
specific virus although even I laugh
sometimes and call it flu there are
three types of influenza virus a B and C
we're going to predominately talk about
a and B type C influenza is a much less
common cause of illness in humans
primarily it's affecting young children
a very rare cause of illness in adults
influenza A viruses in contrast to B and
C in fact not only humans but also
animals
such as
birds horses and pigs and this will be
very important as we'll talk about in
just a moment and another key aspect of
the virus is that the influenza viruses
undergo frequent genetic mutations a
little anatomy of the influenza virus
this is a number of the constituents of
the virus I focus on just two here two
outer proteins of the virus
hemagglutinin and neuraminidase often
abbreviated will be abbreviated H and n
hemagglutinin is a glycoprotein on the
surface of influenza viruses that's
responsible for binding the virus to
cells of the respiratory tract
neuraminidase is another surface protein
it's an enzyme that are now enabled the
virus to be released from the host cell
and it's required for viral replication
some influenza nomenclature viruses get
names they get named as to their type a
B or C the geographic source where the
specific virus was first isolated in
this case California and isolate numbers
which was a fourth such virus that was
identified the year of isolation in this
case 2009 and then influenza A viruses
get further subtype as to the specific
hemagglutinin neuraminidase this is an
h1n1 virus and as you may have already
recognized the virus I've that's being
named here is the pandemic 2009 virus
that was first identified in a in
children in California so the other
thing I said was that the viruses
undergo frequent genetic mutation there
are two types of mutations the first
type is antigenic drift and these are
minor minor mutations in the
hemagglutinin and neuraminidase within
one subtype so you have an influenza A
it's an h1n1
it's a USSR 1977 it drifts and it
becomes an h1n1 Brazil 1978 antigenic
drift occurs in types a B and C
influenza we still have partial immunity
from exposure previous similar viruses
but it's this energetic drift that's
responsible for our annual epidemics of
influenza in cartoon form this is what
happens with antigenic drift you can see
here there's a minor mutation in the
hemagglutinin a minor change it's still
the same hñ subtype but it's drifted and
as a result of this drift as I said you
have these annual influenza epidemics
these epidemics
tech specific geographical areas they're
seasonal and so these these drifts are
one of the major causes of seasonal flu
the attack rates due to epidemics are
lower than in pandemics which I've not
yet defined and the major affects what
we see every year increased rates of
hospitalization increased absenteeism
from work in school and arise and excess
mortality people die from flu if you
look at the burden of influenza United
States the CDC looked at the years 2010
through 2016 shown on the left and
there's a range the severity of flu
seasons varies year-to-year based on the
types that are circulating specific
types circulating weather we've seen
them before the match between the
strains in the vaccine and the types
that are circulating and and the
difference between the different types
of cells in terms of the severity of
disease they caused so between 2010 and
2016 CDC estimated about 12,000 to
56,000 deaths per year 140,000 to over
700,000 hospitalizations in year and
tens of millions of cases
this past flu season 2017-2018 was
characterized as a high severity season
high levels of influenza like illness
visits high hospitalization rates and an
estimated 80,000 deaths so think about
that for a second
if I said that there was an infectious
disease that caused between 12,000 and
eighty thousand deaths a year among
Americans you probably say oh I wish we
had a vaccine to prevent that well
indeed there is such a disease and there
is such a vaccine and yet many people
who would benefit from vaccination don't
get vaccinated the 27th 2018 season was
a predominant influenza A H 3n2 season
and historically h3n2 seasons tend to be
more severe than h1n1 seasons why was it
so feet was so severe again h3n2 was a
predominant strain in addition the
vaccine was not as effective as we would
have liked it to be it's never going to
be a hundred percent protective not with
the current formulations of vaccines but
the effectiveness against a h3n2 that
was the predominant vaccine type
circulating was only about twenty five
percent the overall effectiveness
against the circulating pipes was about
40 percent now whether you see this as a
path last full or half empty depends on
your views of life not ideal you can
still get influenza after getting the
flu shot but it still it offers you the
best chance of being protected and if
you can reduce your risk by 25 percent
40 percent 50 percent you should take
advantage of that bottom line a lot of
disease caused by influenza every year
in the United States and talking about
deaths if you look historically in
general more than 90 percent of deaths
due to influenza each year occur in
people 65 years of age and older
and that's why historically has been so
much emphasis so much focus on making
sure that adults and particularly
elderly get vaccinated
but it's not only adults who get sick
and adults who die children actually are
more likely to get influenza primarily
because of their intimate contact with
other children and their lack of
pre-existing immunity particularly not
been vaccinated and children do die and
so pediatric deaths due to influenza are
reportable and if you look back over the
past decade or so or longer it's about a
hundred children die every year from
influenza in line with last year being a
more severe season the number of deaths
reported was over a hundred eighty many
of these children do have underlying
conditions but many of them also have
are otherwise healthy and so to protect
our children from influenza they should
be vaccinated the other side benefit
which I mention again later is that
children of the vectors in the community
and so vaccine them also protects all
the people the adults the grandparents
that they come in contact with
so that's antigenic drift responsible
for our annual epidemics of influenza
the other type of mutation is antigenic
shift and this is a major change for an
old to a new viral subtype for example
from h2 n 2 to H 3 n 2 as results of
reassortment between two side types
antigenic shift occurs only among type a
influenza viruses it's a new virus with
a novel antigenic profile the population
does not have antibodies and this is
what results in pandemics antigenic
shift so in cartoon form you've got as I
said influenza viruses influence a
viruses that affect not only humans but
animals such as birds including ducks
you've got two influenza A virus that
infects humans and influenza a virus
that infect the Ducks and then the virus
can reassert oftentimes with it infect a
common host such as a pig
and in the pig the viruses reassortment
doesn't occur commonly but when it does
occur you wind up with a novel virus in
this case a virus that has a
hemagglutinin from the duck or avians
type of influenza and the neuraminidase
from the the human type and so now
you've got a novel virus and this is
what can lead to pandemics so pandemics
follow em genic shifts historically
occurred cycles every ten to forty years
and affects the entire globe the onset
could be any season not just wintertime
high attack rates in all age groups and
morbidity and mortality are markedly
increased so if you look over the past
hundred years now before the most recent
pandemics here were the three other
pandemics the so-called Spanish flu was
a hundred years ago we're celebrating
the hundredth anniversary of the Spanish
flu this was the worst pandemic of the
20th century estimated approximately 50
million people around the world died
from Spanish flu
about 40 years later the Asian flu and
h2n2 flu caused severe disease ten years
later the Hong Kong flu h3n2 caused
moderate disease and then we're waiting
and waiting and then in 2009 h1n1 and
we'll return to that topic in just a
moment what I'd like to emphasize here
though is that when a pandemic virus
kicks it looks different than the
typical and its impact looks different
than the typical seasonal flu so I've
already mentioned that in you know with
the annual epidemics about 90 percent or
more the deaths occur in people 65 years
of age and older when you've got a
pandemic virus a new virus a novel virus
that changes so if you look back at the
Spanish flu 1918 1919 h1n1 virus in that
first year 99% of the deaths are Curtin
people younger than 65 years of age you
look 30 years 25 years in the future
so the third of the deaths occurred in
people under 65 and then the current or
the recent h1n1 you're back to baseline
the Asian flu in 57 58 more than a third
of deaths and that first year current
people under 65 the Hong Kong flu almost
half of deaths occur in people 65 so
it's a very different pattern than you
see with seasonal flu
you
let me switch gears a little bit and
talk about in avian influenza and as I
said the so for example the 1918 1919
Spanish flu was an avian flu and so part
of pandemic preparedness is to see
what's going on in the world not only
among humans little bit among animals
including birds because we know that's
often times that the strains that affect
us it becomes a pandemic strains start
in other species so avian influenza is
an infectious disease of birds it's
caused by influenza a virus strains
there 15 known subtypes that affect
birds the avian flu and birds causes a
wide spread of disease ranging from mild
illness to a highly contagious and
rapidly fatal disease the highly
pathogenic strains tend to be of two
types h5 and h7 usually avian influenza
strains did not infect species other
than birds and pigs but that's not
always true
Hong Kong in 1997 had a major outbreak
of avian flu was an h1 h5n1 virus and
Taipei h5n1 had been first discovered in
1961 in turns and turns her type of
phallus not in turns and then in 1997
thousands of chickens in Hong Kong died
due to h5n1 in May 1997 the h5n1 h5n1
virus was isolated from a three year old
boy and between May and December 28 1997
there were 18 confirmed cases one
suspected case broad age range in five
deaths due to h5n1 in people and the
concern at the time appropriately so was
now you had a novel virus that could
infect humans and make them very sick
and the concern was this could be the
next pandemic
you'll notice in the last bullet here it
says December 28 1997 what happens on
December 28 why did this outbreak so
abruptly kind of halt well the reason is
that on December 20th it started killing
all the chickens
and the the reason h5n1 to this day has
not become a has not become a pandemic
virus as we learned that while the virus
could infect humans and make them very
sick the transmission was almost
exclusively exclusively from chickens to
people so as humans had close contact
with sick chickens the virus is not
transmitted easily from person to person
and therefore it has not become a
pandemic strain nonetheless over the
subsequent 20 years h5n1 infected birds
were subtly reported not only from Hong
Kong but through various areas in Asia
Africa and Europe birds fly and there
were a number of human cases and again
you can see the high deaths due to h5
and one
but again 20 years later it has not
become a pandemic strain more recently
in 2013
human sections with a another novel
influenza A virus and 8 7 and 9 were
first reported in China since 2013 more
than 1,500 cases in humans and 600
deaths again a nasty virus you can see
the epidemiologic curve on the right
more cases this past year than in the
previous years but again no evidence
that the virus is transmitted easily
from person to person and so this is
something needs to be monitored the
viruses can you taint and become more
easily transmissible in which case they
could become a pandemic virus but as
that has not occurred to date and so if
you were to have tried to predict 10
years ago what's going to the next
pandemic strain and you are a betting
person you have said it's probably going
to be an avian influenza strain and will
probably originated in Southeast Asia of
course that turned out not to be the
case which again just speaks to the
unpredictability of influenza so let's
talk briefly about the 2009 h1n1
pandemic outbreak the flu so this was a
swine influenza A and we first became
aware of it
in April 2009 when it was recovered from
two children in Southern California and
these children did not have contacts
with pigs they didn't have contact with
each other and the virus contained a
unique combination of gene segments that
previously not been reported among swine
or human influenza viruses in the United
States or elsewhere
and so with the identification of these
novel viruses that could infect people
you know everywhere on on high alert
what's what's happening and what we
recognized that was happening was that
starting in March and early April 2009
there were outbreaks of an
influenza-like illness in several areas
of the country on April 23rd this novel
h1n1 virus the swine flu virus was
confirmed and control measures were
instituted you know the next day they
closed schools that discourage large
public gathering what trying to figure
out what's going on
when we look in the United States it
wasn't limited just to the two kids in
California and by the time we recognized
it is already spread significantly even
in the United States as we learn more
and more in the week that had the swine
flu went through this cycle about what
it was doing in its perception and and
in the initial weeks there was a lot of
hysteria and people were panicky about
what was going to happen what turned out
of course was that fortunately for us
h1n1 disease in humans was generally
mild to moderate and to solve the
conclusion became was just a lot of hype
well first of all the problem with that
is at the start you don't know how it's
going to progress and so you've got to
take it extremely seriously and get
ready and the other point is it wasn't
just a benign illness so if you look at
the pandemic strain you can see 12,000
deaths or so 275,000 hospitalizations
not not worse than a normal flu year in
lots and lots of cases but the striking
thing here is look at the deaths again
right because it's usually 90% you know
or seven people over 65 there skews more
left the hospitalizations are skewed far
to the left and so this was a may had a
major impact in young children and it
was predominately pediatric hospitals
urgent care centers pediatric you know
ers that saw the brunt of this illness
and got swamped from it because it was
the kids that were getting that we're
getting sick in addition the the deaths
in children were about four to five
times what we've seen a normal year just
again to highlight the difference this
was just for the first couple months of
the outbreak in blue our
hospitalizations by age in a normal
seasonal year with the pandemic in black
there you can see again the
hospitalizations are skewed to younger
individuals so it was bad but not nearly
as bad as it could have been and just
because the virus didn't cause serious
disease
we learned a lot from the pandemic in
2009 we learned a lot about how we're
not as well prepared as we'd like to be
and we learned a lot about diagnosis of
influenza and the outbreak really shone
a light on influenza diagnostic
capabilities and some of limitations so
let's talk about diagnosis of influenza
so first of all why diagnose influenza
generally a self-limited illness well
there are variety of reasons one you can
provide specific antiviral therapy for
indicated patients and it we'll talk
about a little later there's benefits to
treating influenza in addition you avoid
things that you don't need you avoid
unnecessary antibiotics which obviously
can have a negative impact for the
patient you avoid unnecessary
evaluations for other cause of illness
as I'll show you in just a moment making
a specific diagnosis means fewer
unnecessary tests if you were
unnecessary therapies in hospitalized
patients we hate it when a hospital as
patient is there for something else
develops a new fever what's going on is
this some major complication a
post-operative infection knowing do they
need it we need to change their
antibiotics for something we're treating
or does it happen to be not good but
does it have to only be a hoss acquired
infection a viral infection and so we
don't need to really escalate therapy or
escalate diagnosis it also helps isolate
hospitalized patients appropriately and
understand what's going on in the
community so just a couple quick slides
the impact of making a diagnosis just
two short studies that look at rapid
test rapid testing for influenza in
adults in adults and children first and
adults this is a retrospective study
hospitalized patients with influenza
whose engine test was positive compared
to those who had negative types of rapid
test was not done but they had influenza
those who has a rapid test that was
positive they had less antibiotic use
greater antiviral use that's good for
the patient
however many a deposit a should still
receive the antibody despite the absence
of an indication and you know one
thing's going to do is educate
clinicians and they've got to feel
comfortable that the diagnosis is
correct and they don't have to look for
other things to explain it which doesn't
mean that some patients with influenza
don't need antibiotics of course in
children this is a prospective study of
febrile children seen in Edie and
Alabama all the patients had a rapid
test that obtained while they were in
the Eady but in half the patients the
test wasn't done till 24 hours later in
patients who are positive for influenza
those were the rapid tests done in the
IDI fewer tests you were CDC's fewer
blood cultures fewer tests x-rays human
cultures they all spent less time in the
IDI and have fewer antibiotics
prescribed those are tremendous outcomes
that's a big impact right
also emphasize here they're using rapid
tests how much better would be with a
more sensitive test so you have more
confidence in the diagnosis and you make
the app diagnosis more accurately more
frequently so who should be tested these
are from guidelines published by the
infection C Society of America in 2009
so during influenza season and I'd
emphasize that it should be during the
season testing should occur in the
following persons with febrile
respiratory symptoms if the result will
influence clinical management
so certainly outpatient you know common
image of competent persons or at high
risk of complications and we'll talk
about those these are the people who for
whom you know vaccine is really
recommended because they're at risk of
diseases so people with asthma heart
disease diabetes etc
in addition outpatient immunocompromised
persons and then hospitalized people and
I think that you know every hospitalized
patient
who's coming it was a farewell resinous
should be evaluated for influenza you
know if not also for other respiratory
viruses
who else should be tested during
influenza season testing should occur
the following persons if the result will
influence clinical management so people
at the extremes of age LD persons and
infants presenting with suspected sepsis
or fever on an origin in those age
groups they are less likely to have
classic influenza symptoms including
respiratory symptoms children with fever
and respiration is presenting for
evaluation and people who develop fever
respiratory symptoms after admission
because unfortunately hospital acquired
viral risk for infections are still too
common
the CDC has guidelines for who to
consider for influenza testing I'm not
going to go through the whole thing but
I just want to make a couple points
first of all they assigned some some
suggested influenza yes the rid of the
hospitals yes test them
start empiric antibiotic while you're
waiting for testing results I'll
reinforce that later and the real thing
I want to emphasize here on the bottom
left hand corner molecular assays should
be used for influenza testing of
hospitalized patients you want the most
sensitive test available and that's
going to be a molecular test and they
will talk about interpretation of
testing results
as all of you know we've got a wide
variety of influenza virus testing
methodologies and these have evolved
over time
you know classically you know viral
tissue cell culture that was the gold
standard it yields live virus the major
drawback of course is the time you know
you're not getting results oftentimes
you know the rapid culture techniques
obviously improve that but you know
you're not getting when you want it when
you most want it we're going to have the
biggest impact on on clinical management
you know the immunofluorescence staining
DSA or IFA you know more rapid results
but it will talk about not quite as
sensitive we're going to talk about the
rapid or the diagnostic test which is to
come increasingly common increasingly
use there and detection you get results
you know in 15-20 minutes but they've
got drawbacks as the CDC guidelines
suggest you know we're really in a
molecular age now and as a variety of
diagnostic testing methodologies and
platforms but but these have become
really the gold standard and and where
you want to be if you have the biggest
impact on clinical management of
patients
I said that the 2009 h1n1 pandemic
really shone a light on the Diagnostics
and this is from a study published in
late 2009 a large study where they
looked at over 6,000 patient samples
submitted for h1n1 testing over a
five-week period assuming for influenza
testing over a five-week period and they
looked at a variety of different testing
methodology including rapid engine tests
DFAS viral cultures and PCR and the the
big take home message was the
sensitivities so the symptoms of two
rapid tests were 18 percent and 48
percent respectively in other words one
of the rapid tests missed more than 80
percent of the positives the other
missed more than half BSA missed half
the Polizzi the positive influenzas
viral culture got 90% of them but as I
said molecular testing PCR was the gold
standard and I think this a 2009
outbreak stage one and one outbreak
really drove you know molecular retro
test testing in general and
appropriately so there have been a
number of other looks at the rapid tests
the number of analyses this is the most
recent one published this meta-analysis
of 162 studies compared these rapid
tests the newer digital amido assays
that have an inserted based digital scan
of the test strip and so it takes away
some of the subjectivity of the classic
rapid tests and you know the the a rapid
nucleic acid amplification test a
molecular test in children adults with
suspected influenza the bottom line
showed in the second bullet the pool
sensitivity for the rapid tests was 54%
you're missing half the cases
for the dia is better 80% for the
molecular tests 90 92% again
highlighting the deficiencies of the
rapid tests in this study the
sensitivities for detecting influenza B
were similar to influenza A other
studies have shown differences we also
intend to be differences between
children and adults a test and a child a
rapid test a child more likely positives
and a rapid test and adults the reason
for that is that children tend to shed
higher titers of virus there's more
virus and so the tests are are better
and children than adults in general CDC
guidance on the rapid tests highlighting
the limitations of sensitivity I
emphasize the second bullet point here
that the positive and negative
predictive values vary considerably and
it's dependent on the prevalence of
influenza the population being tested
what does that mean if you do a rapid
test
in a patient in August when you don't
have influenza virus circulating the
community any positive you get is almost
surely going to be a false positive
whereas if you do the test for the virus
is very common you can be much more
confident that a rapid test that's
positive truly represents an infection
and so at the beginning at the end of
this season their function utility is
lower and again at the beginning and the
season a molecular assays will give you
better more accurate results and tell
you what's going on in the community the
bottom line is that a negative rapid
test does not exclude the possibility of
influenza virus infection and again this
is something we learned in in 2009 very
clearly I remember very vividly a lab
director and one of our local hospitals
was sending us that's was that they had
tested for influenza at the beginning of
the h1n1 outbreak and what they were
doing is we developed a test that could
specifically identify the 2009 h1n1
pandemic strain so they have a positive
rapid test for influenza A they send it
to us and we would confirm that it was
the 2009 h1n1 or or that it wasn't one
day by mistake they sent us their
negatives
and I forget the number so they set us
about seven or eight negative rapid test
for influenza on three or four of them
we identify it as 2009 h1n1 positive and
the lab directed call me and said I
think you have a problem with your test
and I had to correctly kindly explain to
our notes not a problem our test it's a
problem with your test and you know we
had all learned that the rapid test had
deficiencies you're probably aware that
as a result of everything we've learned
over the past decade in 2017 the FDA
reclassify the rapid tests from class 1
to class 2 devices with new minimums
performance standards and a requirement
for annual reactivity testing and the
goal is to ensure the reliability of
accuracy of the rapid tests reduce the
likelihood of false negative results and
thereby aid clinicians we're trying to
use the results to help patients as a
consequence many previously available
rapid tests can no longer be purchased
in the United States and and here is
what the reclassification does it
identifies the minimum acceptable
performance criteria requires use of a
currently appropriate and FDA accepted
comparative method which giving a
molecular method for establishing the
performance of new engine based rapid
tests and I think also very
interestingly importantly require annual
analytic reactivity testing of
contemporary influenza virus strains and
require Analects analytic reactivity
testing of newly emerging strains under
certain conditions and and so the CDC
now has a panel of viruses against which
the rapid tests are be tested with each
year to make sure that they're able to
detect the viruses that are circulating
in the infants of a potentially emergent
virus they'll do the same thing to make
sure that the rapid tests that are
already available can actually detect
new viruses that may be circulating or
the commonly circulating strains so so
here is just one example of possible
problems there was an h3n2 variant virus
it's a swine virus that several years
ago was affecting pigs in the Midwest
United States and infected some humans
as well and they were people who had
contact with the pigs
itit because they you know work on a
fall
at petting zoos etc and so that led to a
nexus of some of these rapid tests well
they looked at the rapid tests they
could detect the seasonal h3n2 the human
strains and all the one detective the
pandemic h1n1 all these variants strain
viruses and the hypothesis was that the
reduced sensitivity the rapid test the
variant virus was due to differences in
the nucleoprotein the swine influenza
the point being so that not only do we
want to treat our patients but we've got
to be alert to the fact that as new
viruses emerge our tests may not be as
good and then as the virus drifts our
tests may not be as good and so this is
extremely important I'd also emphasize
this is a potential problem not only
with rapid tests but some of the
molecular assays they have different
targets and so as new viruses emerge as
your mutations we've got to be sure that
our molecular tests are one able to
detect the novel virus and if they are
able to detect it can they determine
what type it is accurately as well and
so because the influenza viruses mutate
we've done be consistently reevaluating
the tests that we're using to make sure
that they are staying up to date with
the virus as it evolves
so what we've seen over the past 30
years is a real evolution in viral
diagnostic testing not only for
influenza but other respiratory viruses
we've gone from viral culture to source
an antibody testing to rapid and
rejection and more recently the highly
sensitive molecular tests as well as a
trend of testing at or near the point of
care and this trend is only going to
accelerate until I believe like you're
testing at or near the point of care
becomes routine we want the best tests
available to give us a timely result in
time so it impacts our madison to
patients and so that's that's where we
that's where many of us are and the rest
of us will be going because that's where
we want to be
switching gears now to spend a little
bit of time on on treatment the the main
stage therapies are neuraminidase
inhibitors there are three available the
United States the one you know most
commonly is awful time of year available
now is a generic version or the trade
name Tamiflu and this is a you know
padlet you take for five days the Nama
veer is an inhaled
Nermin today's inhibitor you can't use
in people who've got respiratory
illnesses like asthma and forever veer
is a more recent antiviral given
intravenously the exciting news is a
couple of weeks ago bilac severe was
licensed in the United States and it's
the first new anti viral influenza
treatment with a novel mechanism
actually approved in almost 20 years
it's been approved to treat
uncomplicated influenza in patients 12
years of age and older who had symptoms
for no more than two days and I've
emphasized here that there's no more
than two days it's really true for all
the antiviral anti-influenza therapies
you want to start as early as possible
the greatest clinical impact is seen
when you start a brilliant disease
course for most patients you know it's a
four five six day illness you know you
starting it at day five in general is
not going to have a large impact or any
impact that you'll be able to measure at
all that's not to say that you don't use
it in high-risk patients or very sick
patients more than two days out but if
you're gonna have an impact in the
patient you're seeing in the IDI the
urgent care center just hospitalized you
want to start as early possible which
again speaks to the need to make a
diagnosis early this is from the
efficacy trial it's a single dose oral
medication so that's kind of cool you
know it's one dose and so now you can
see where you know you can really impact
a patient's clinical course if you can
make a diagnosis and treat them and
complete the treatment in the same visit
single dose oral medications to do
significant reduce the duration of
symptoms like more than one day and the
efficacy was comparable to the awful
time of year you can see on the right
you know the the impact is not
tremendous but you're making people
better reducing fever reducing symptoms
by more than a day on average and for
the patient's ill that that's really you
know that's that significant they get
back to work a day early they're gonna
take care of their family a day earlier
they get back to school a day earlier
they're shedding less virus making them
less contagious to others so you know
this is not meant to minimize the
potential impact of effective therapy
given a diagnosis of influenza and again
having another drug in our armamentarium
is obviously a very good thing so the
summary early antivirus antivirus
therapy people with influenza can lessen
illness severity shorten the type of
illness and reduce lubricated
flu-related complications and again to
re-emphasize clinicians should not delay
decisions about starting antiviral
therapy while waiting for laboratory
confirmation of influenza if there's a
strong reason to treat don't wait for
the test results
but again the better answer is get your
test results quickly so you can treat
those who most need it influenza
2018-2019 just around the corner
the CDC every week publishes updates on
influenza activity the map and the week
ending October 27th there's not a lot
going on a couple states have some local
activity there's some sporadic activity
but in the weeks ahead we expect this
map to start changing as influenza
season hits one of the ways the
government of the CDC looks for
influenza is looking at ili influenza
like illness in outpatients and not all
ili is influenza but measurement tells
you when influenza
starts the gray lines of on the left
that's the the 2009 pandemic
the season started when kids went back
to school so it was a really
september/october illness by November
December it was pretty much gone
the teal that peaks in the middle that's
last season 2017-2018 you can see higher
peak kind of broader peak as well it was
a severe season the red diamonds that
you see in the bottom in the left that's
this year 2018 2019 and you can see
allies slowly starting to tick up that
dashed line would it hit 2.2 we're
saying that influenza season if you were
betting you say we're probably three
four weeks away from from influenza
season but we'll see how it goes and
we'll see what what the year is like
finally prevention and the primary means
of prevention is flu vaccine the
recommendations for the use of influenza
vaccine this year routine annual
influenza vaccination is recommended for
all people six months of age and older
who don't have a contradict a ssin with
any licensed age-appropriate flu vaccine
and there's no preference Express for
any one vaccine over another
vaccinations should be offered by the
end of October all the people in costume
that you saw in that that first that
first slide they've all been vaccinate
against flu but it's not too late if
you've not gotten your flu vaccine if
your loved ones of not gone when it's
not too late and vaccination efforts
should continue throughout the season
because the duration of the flu season
varies activity does not necessarily
occur only in December January and lasts
until February or March
so bottom line it's not too late
routine vaccination is recommended but
there are certain individuals for whom
there's a high risk of medical
complications and they should get an
increased focus for flu vaccines all
children 6 months to 6 years of age
all people 50 years of age and older
adults and children with underlying
conditions that increase the risk
chronic lung conditions including asthma
heart disease kidney disease liver
disease diabetes
people are able to compromise due to any
reason
women who are will be pregnant during
flu season and this is for two reasons
one and this was again emphasized during
the 2009 h1n1 pandemic women who are
pregnant are at higher risk of serious
influenza disease they're probably
higher risk for two reasons one the more
pregnant they are they're bigger their
belly is less long lung volume they have
and they're also immune system is not
quite normal when they've got a foreign
body that they're going to deliver and
so we saw and we heard of otherwise
healthy pregnant women who got severely
ill and died from influenza during the
2009 pandemic so vaccine pregnant and
protects them it also protects their
unborn babies through passive immunity
the the infant gets of influenza
antibodies then can help protect them
when they're a youngest and most at risk
so pregnant women should be vaccinated
children adolescents getting aspirin
because the risk of Reye's syndrome
residents of nursing homes and other
long-term care facilities American
Indians Alaska Natives and people who
are extremely obese again it's really
recommended it at all but the groups
we've talked about we should put a
special emphasis on making sure that
they get vaccinated in addition people
who live or care for these people and
are there for it risk for influenza
rated complication be vaccinated health
care personnel I mean you know first do
no harm if we get sick and we're taking
care of patients we're putting them at
risk and so unfortunately historically
health care workers broadly defined have
not done a good job of vaccine we've not
done a good job of acting ourselves
increased emphasis and as you know many
hospitals other health care facilities
are really pushing and in many cases
requiring that the people taking care of
patients get vaccinated and then finally
the last two bullets household contacts
of high risk individuals should be
vaccinated so household contacts and
caregivers of particularly children and
the very young children
adults should be vaccinated where
Grandma and Grandpa we're gonna be a
highest risk of complications highest
risk of death going to get flu from to
get it from their grandkids and so
vaccine children protect them protect
themselves and protects their loved ones
over the past number of years we've seen
the fortunes of different flu vaccines
available in different types and this
can this can only help us
there are quadrivalent and and trivalent
vaccines the quadrivalent vaccines have
to a predictive to a types and 2b types
the trivalent have to a's and 1b again
there is no preference for any specific
type as long as it's not contraindicated
the most important thing is that you get
vaccinated against influenza you can see
a list of the quadrivalent there I point
out the fourth one is a cell culture
grown influenza vaccine most the all the
others listed here they're grown in egg
egg cell culture and so that's a newer
way of doing it there's also a
quadrivalent recombinant vaccines flu
bot blue block quadrivalent so not even
grown in in cell culture there was also
a a report study this past year that
suggested that it might be more
effective than a traditional inactivated
cell culture grown vaccine but again
more information is needed before making
a recommendation you see the trivalent
here I just put up this the first one is
the high dose vaccine a number of
studies have now shown that in people 65
years of age and older it looks to be
more effective than the standard dose
vaccine I make sure my mom gets the high
dose vaccine every year and then the
final one is the live attenuated vaccine
the nasal spray vaccine flu this flu
mist available this year if not after
not being available the past couple
years it was not available recommend in
the past couple years because for a
couple years for some reason it was not
effective against the h1n1 virus is the
pandemic strain that was circulating
that appears to have been resolved now
it's available for those who absolutely
do not want shots it is certainly a very
good option and before it was pulled
temporarily there was evidence that it
was better in children than the standard
inactivated vaccine the flu shot all of
my kids got the flu shot this year
because that's time we went our
pediatrician had not received flu mist
so the summary annual epidemics of
influenza results in significant
morbidity and mortality flu affects not
only those at high risk but even the
healthy and so we should all be
protected as best we can the accurate
diagnosis of influenza infection can
provide benefits to the individual
patient and to the community and as I
said you know molecular diagnostics that
give you more rapid results are where
many of us are and where the rest of us
need to be heading and then finally
annual immunizations the most effective
strategy to prevent influenza unless
there's a contradiction you and your
loved ones and the people you work with
whether or not you love them should be
vaccinated against influenza
that concludes my presentation at this
time if you have any questions or
comments I would welcome them thank you
dr. Lieberman for your presentation
quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions simply type them
into the drop-down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
labeled ask a question and click on the
send button
dr. Lieberman will answer as many
questions as time permits
first question is why are birds and pigs
the main flue reservoir in which
antigenic shifts occur
so the shift actually occurs in various
places but it's the avian and swine flu
viruses that have most commonly been
involved in human pandemics so for the
different animals so it affects not only
Birds and takes in humans but horses
dogs cats there are specific H&N
subtypes that infect different animal
species and so the types that affect
horses for example different age types
don't have the capacity to infect humans
the specific virus is sort of human you
know Hema gluten for example is not able
to attach to human cells but what could
happen is that the viruses mutate and
over time they evolve and the classic
shift occurs as I said when you have two
different viruses that reassortment so
what you need is a two viruses that can
infect one speech is an intermediate
host and so this is a classic type is
that you get an avian flu strain and a
human flu strain each of which could
infect a pig and while in that Pig the
virus is reassortant you want with a
novel virus and so it takes a lot for
antigenic shift which is why it doesn't
occur very commonly at all most of the
time if it does it's a dead end it
doesn't can infect other species or even
make that the original species SiC but
everyone's too wrong while you get the
right combination occur and you wind up
with a potentially deadly virus and it's
all related to you know mutations and
it's a highly mutable virus and you know
and then what kind of contact do you
have do you have contact between these
different animals between pigs and
animals between pigs and birds between
those pigs and humans and so
takes a lot and we don't fully
understand the dynamics and why that why
that occurs thank you for that next one
is you know hospital setting or clinical
caretakers have more and more
responsibilities for lab testing which
takes away from their time to care for
the patient how important is it to have
the flu result at the point of care
so so as a clinician my general
philosophy was knowledge is power you
know when you're asking me to see a
patient or I'm going to see a patient
I've got two major responsibilities one
what's going on what's the diagnosis and
then second what do I do about it
but it all starts with what's going on
what do you what do you have and so any
information I have that helps me
understand what's going on
dramatically reduces the time that I
need to then formulate the diagnostic
plan so knowledge is power and you know
does it have to be at the point of care
well it depends on what's going on
obviously but you know if I'm seeing the
patient now if I know what they have
there's all the benefits I've already
talked about let's let's get let me not
waste time doing unnecessary tasks
unnecessary procedures providing the
necessary therapies let's let's focus in
what I know you have and so you know you
want Diagnostics at or near the point of
care I don't mind if I have to wait 15
minutes is ideal if I have to wait two
hours I can still use that information
what you know very well if I've got away
three days I've lost a lot of the
potential utility and waste of time and
potentially not treated or mistreated or
over treated or over diagnosed and so so
point of care is literally where it's at
thank you next one is are there any
other viruses that should be tested for
when a patient presents with flu-like
symptoms
so I really thinks it depends on the
setting and the patient again knowledge
is power and so the question is how will
a diagnosis impact my evaluation
treatment of the patient you know any in
the out so one thing is does it does it
impact how I treat influence that we've
got antivirals so if I know I have a
diagnosis of influenza I have a specific
therapy that I can give depending on the
patient where they are their illness etc
that I can use to make the patient
better and so that's that's powerful for
the hospitalized patient knowing that
again the cause of their fever is a
specific respiratory virus it's RSV
that's that's powerful again I don't
have to worry that they have some other
complication it helps me isolate the
patient effectively that's powerful as
well and so will hospitalized patients
I'm more likely to want to know what
they have specifically and having it you
know it expanded diagnosis you know what
what do they have in the outpatient
setting you know I don't need to know
that every child who presents with a
runny nose and a fever that they've got
a rhinovirus really doesn't help me
knowing they have influenza you know I
could do something specifically knowing
that they have RSV for example it's a
six month old that's going to heighten
my concern about their clinical course
but I think because I know how
significant bronchiolitis can be and so
it may not impact my initial manage of
the patient but may cause me to follow
up closer with the patient and so so
that could be very powerful as well so
again bottom line it depends on the
setting depends on the patient but
knowledge is power thank you next one is
why was last food season so severe since
even people who are vaccinated were
getting the flu
well it was so severe for a number of
reasons some of which I've already
highlighted it was an h3n2 predominant
season and those seasons tend to be more
severe as I also said unfortunately the
vaccine was not as effective as we would
have liked it to have been only 25%
protective in general against the
predominant strain but another reason I
think the contribute to the fact that
fewer people were vaccinated there was a
recent report
I forget the the precise numbers but
among adults it was something like 6%
fewer adults were vaccinated last season
compared to the previous season and I
don't understand that vaccination
coverage among children was pretty much
the same and I would highlight that
knowledge was coverage was lower it's
still low even the year before was low
as we liked it today realize every
person that gets back against influenza
not only reduces their old likelihood of
getting sick but reduce the likelihood
of other people getting sick and so you
know we want for ourselves and for
others for as many people get back
sighted as possible thank you
looks like we have time for one more
question what is the prediction for this
coming foo season in terms of severity
and which strings will be circulating
one of my favorite quotes is that though
making predictions is is very difficult
especially when it's about the future
and so I hesitate to make predictions
and everyone thought we get totally
surprised
so far if you look at what's circulating
in the United States and again it's only
sporadic activity it's predominantly
influenza a viruses and so far what we
know is they appear to be good matches
with the strains in the vaccine so that
that bodes well could change but that's
that's comforting and the CDC continues
to monitor that we also know last was a
very severe h3n2 season lots of illness
it tends to cycle a little bit a lot of
people got sick it makes it less likely
that for example h3n2 would be as severe
this season another source of
information comes to what happens in the
southern hemisphere
so you know that you know their winter
is you know six months different from up
in the north we have in the northern
hemisphere
and so their influenza season ended you
know August September or so in their
influenza season the pandemic h1n1 virus
was the most common type so if you were
to make a prediction you would think
that would probably be an h1n1
predominant season that might be and
would tend to be less severe than last
season but again I wouldn't put any
money on it and you should treat it as
this could be another bad year make sure
you get vaccinated protect yourselves
and your loved ones thank you oh sorry
we have one more question um discussion
is on the first slide is this Captain
Kirk or Captain Picard that is jean-luc
Picard that's Star Trek The Next
Generation Love Kirk but you can find a
better leader than jean-luc
like to once again thank dr. Lieberman
for his presentation I'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration we would like to
thank our sponsor daya soar and
molecular for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through May twenty
nineteen lab routes will alert you via
email when it's available for replay and
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye